SPEAKER 1: --see that grow
and see that bloom as everyone
all over the world kind
of jumped on and put
these connections together.
I've been witness to a few
large changes on the web.
And the web is
interesting in that I
think it evolves as a
platform in a way that's
pretty unique, compared to
other platforms as well.
The first evolution
was Ajax when we kept
adding capabilities to the web.
We wanted to make it
prettier, so we added styling
with CSS and the like.
And we wanted to do
more dynamic interfaces,
so we added JavaScript.
But we kept pushing
and kept pushing.
And when someone on the
Outlook web team at Microsoft
put together the XMLHttpRequest
object that kind of birthed
the Ajax movement, we got to
go from this world of documents
and kind of rich documents,
and really kind of blow
up and allow you to build
real web applications.
And we remember that with
immersive apps like Google
Maps, Gmail, and Google Suggest
and the like on the Google
side.
And this was a
massive difference.
And you go back and think about
what it was like before that.
I remember going to
MapQuest, for example,
before Google Maps.
And every time you
wanted to pan around
to another area in there, you
had to wait for the server
to send everything down again.
The web created some
new capabilities,
took a bit of time
to work out how
to deliver on
those capabilities,
and we built the desktop web app
revolution going from documents
to apps, just in time for
the web to take over--
for mobile to take over,
rather, and the big explosion
that happened with mobile.
And now it's easy to
think back and remember
this explosion happening as
though it kind of came out
of nothing.
But for those who had
been around a little bit,
you may remember it was
kind of a long time coming.
I remember going to JavaOne,
back in the Sun days,
and every keynote they'd
be up there talking
about how this is
the year for mobile.
Developers, learn J2ME.
It's going to be huge.
And then it never
happened, until we got
the iPhone, and then Android.
And then mobile
totally took off.
And we got to the point where
mobile has eclipsed desktop
entirely.
I do think it's
important though for us
to remember that it's not that
desktop isn't growing anymore.
It's not that desktop
isn't going away.
So it's really
important that we're
able to build experiences
that actually work there.
I don't know about you,
but there are some services
that I use where it feels like
the team's all off working
on mobile, and I use this to
try to be productive all day.
And nothing's really
changing on the desktop side.
So I'm actually really
proud of the fact that you
can develop things responsively
across desktop and mobile too.
Some scary statistics came
out after mobile really
was taking off and people were
building these native apps.
And I was thinking
about, like, well,
what's actually
happening to the web?
You look at the stats and you
see, wow, only 13% of the time
is spent on the mobile web,
compared to apps, where they're
getting 87% of user time.
That's a little bit dire.
That's not the kind of thing
that we as web developers,
we like to see.
But this is a very
macro statistic.
And it was important for us
to go deeper and take a look
at what actually
was happening there.
And you're going to see
a series of case studies
where we actually go in and
look at different companies
and what's happening to them
to kind of piece apart what's
really happening out there.
One of the things to
piece apart in general
was just, of all of
that time, 80% of it
was spent in the top three
apps that a user has.
So it wasn't about just the
native platform versus web,
it was the actual experiences
that they were working with.
And then if you go
deeper within that,
you see that a lot
of the top apps
are kind of
platforms themselves,
and a lot of the
content that's within it
is actually web content
that's going to different web
services.
So the picture
got a lot muddier.
So let's take a look at
a little bit of what's
going on with the whole
web versus native thing,
as we kind of move forward
from desktop into mobile.
And if you look
at one axis you've
got, what are the
capabilities and what
are the access to
capabilities that you
get from a particular platform?
So in the world of
apps, you obviously
get access to the
entire native platform.
You kind of do all of
the permission modeling
a little bit up front
in the app store,
and some runtime permissions.
And then you kind of get to do
whatever you want from then on.
And you get access to the
places where users really
want to get access
to those experiences,
like the home screen and
the notifications bar
and things of that nature.
So you get access to
all of the capabilities
of the native device.
The web, on the
other hand, doesn't
get access to all of those,
especially back in the day.
But then you add in reach.
And you think about
that magic of the URL
where we got to see with
5miles the difference
that we can make by
upgrading our web experience,
and being able to
just share this URL
and get access to not
only the application,
but potentially directly to
the state that really matters.
And again, I think
back to the old days
and installing software and
the like, compared to being I
would to send a URL to my dad,
who can then just click on it
and get directly
into that experience
and start actually
getting something done.
Another startling
statistic that came out,
again with a macro lens, is
something that doesn't really
make a lot of sense.
How can no one be
downloading any apps?
That doesn't really make sense.
But this is good old
statistics and rounding.
This is all about the fact that
people have kind of slowed down
the number of apps that
they're downloading,
because you've kind of
got the apps that you
want to be working with now.
You've got your favorites.
They're lined up.
Apps you download tend
to be the services
you're really loyal to.
And so if you're a newcomer
coming into the game,
it's really hard
to fight for a spot
directly on that home screen.
You've got to get people to go
through all of this process,
download the app
from the App Store.
That's a really
tricky proposition.
So we've got to struggle
to get access to our users,
and what can we do?
So one thing is,
what if we could
take the benefits of
the web and actually
deliver on the capabilities, and
kind of up level the web again
and give you access
to all of the things
that we actually wanted
and all of the things
that users want to be able
to get work done on mobile?
And that's exactly the work
that we-- not just Google,
but the entire web
community-- have been doing.
This is us enhancing
the platform itself,
learning about what works and
giving you, the developers,
access to the underlying
platform in a way that's
secure for users, in a way that
can be at the end of a URL.
This is why I'm
really excited about--
we had Ajax for the
world of desktop apps,
and we finally got
the capabilities
that you need to deliver
fantastic mobile applications.
And so that's what we mean when
we talk about progressive web
apps.
It basically is just
saying that we're here
for mobile natively on the web.
And we saw this
big transformation
where, I remember at the
beginning, with Ajax,
we talked about the
different technologies that
were involved.
And then over time
it just started to--
it started to mean just
the user experience
itself had been up leveled.
And we're trying to do the same
thing here with PWAs on mobile.
We don't want to
just share, here's
all of the different APIs
that you have access to.
That's really
important, and we're
going to go into those details.
But we really want you to
think about the user experience
itself and how to make sure
that you really kind of up level
that experience
on the mobile web.
Because the partners that
we've been working with now
have really been able
to delight their users.
Because, let's face
it, sometimes you
go on the mobile web and
it's not the best experience.
So if you deliver
something that's
really tantalizing
and delightful,
it's going to be great, and
the results are going to show.
So what do we need
to actually do?
How are we going to up
level the experience
and give you the
capabilities that you
need to deliver to your users?
So the first piece is we
need a reliable experience.
We need to make
sure that users know
that they can use the web
even if the connectivity is
intermittent.
Now this was actually
hard on the web,
because its roots, back in time,
were in a very different world.
You remember back then
when you were connecting
to the internet, it wasn't you
connecting through your phone
to the internet.
It was you connecting your
household to the internet.
You'd go.
You'd get a modem.
You'd start dialing up and
you'd hear that magical sounds
that are coming through the
modem to get you connected.
And now you're jacked
into the Matrix.
You're ready to do things.
And then you have
that fear where
you start doing a big
download or something,
and you hope that
someone doesn't
pick the phone up or call you
and disrupt the entire process.
But it was very binary.
You were either connected to
the internet or you weren't.
That's what the
web was all about.
That's what it was based on,
whether it be on a dialup
or sitting there in a university
on a nice flush T1 line,
you knew that you
were always connected.
If you weren't, you got to
see this guy, the downasaur,
and you weren't happy.
And I've got kids at
this point now back home,
and this really
doesn't make them happy
other than the fact they can
play the little game while they
wait for me to try and
fix the Wi-Fi at home.
This is very, very
frustrating to users.
But what we find
is, there's actually
something that's more hidden
and more frustrating going on,
and something that
we need to tackle
as developers to get these
experiences working reliably.
And that's the notion of Li-Fi.
So you've all
probably experienced
this, where you're
looking at your phone,
and it looks like you're
fully connected to Wi-Fi,
or you're fully connected
to your cell network,
but it doesn't
seem to be working.
We've got this problem where
we're connected to the access
point that may be close
to us, but that doesn't
mean we're actually connected
to the internet itself.
And then when you
start to do something,
you don't see the downasaur.
You're just kind of sitting
there with a spinner trying
to work out what's going on.
We, the web platform
provider, needed
to give you the hook so you
could take ownership over this,
make things still work even
as the network is going
up and down and
all of the issues
that we run into every day on
cell networks and the like.
So that's what
reliability is for us.
It's about making sure
that your users never
see this dinosaur when
they're using your experience,
and you're able to do it.
And as you sit through the
different sessions today,
you're going to see
exactly what it takes
to get rid of this dinosaur.
OK, reliability, that's key.
And that's something
that we need
to kind of keep
teaching users so they
know that when
they go on the web,
it's always working
no matter what.
The next slide is
performance and speed.
Ben in the keynote talked
about the strong focus
that we have there, and how
we're trying to attack it
in different ways with AMP.
That's one option to get
content running really quickly.
But we also needed to put
things into the platform
itself to enable you to make
incredibly fast experiences.
Fast meaning loading
things incredibly quickly
on first load, but also
as your users experience
your application, it's that
buttery smooth environment
that Ben was talking about.
You get 60 frames per second.
It feels like it's right
there with your finger.
It just works as it should.
It's just like native.
Now this performance isn't
just about pleasing your users.
We see time and time again
that performance goes directly
to the bottom line.
Soasta is a company that does
a lot of monitoring out there
for your applications and
applications in the wild.
And they did a famous
study a year or so ago
where they looked
at the bounce rates
in the world of e-commerce
and other vectors,
and they just started to measure
the effects of those bounce
rates depending on how
slow your experience is.
And you can see
there's key moments,
like if your load time
is over three seconds,
there's a bounce rate of 20%.
And as you get
slower and slower,
the bounce rate gets
worse and worse.
So anything you can do
to fix this performance
will instantly bring
more money in the door,
and your users won't
be off to play "Candy
Crush" or some other game.
They will be focused
doing whatever they need
to do with your experience.
Now this was done
a year or so ago.
The DoubleClick team
just did another study,
and things have
gotten even worse.
53% of users abandon sites that
take longer than three seconds.
This is a wake up call for
us on the web and in general.
We need to fix the
obesity epidemic
that we have on the web.
We need to deliver
faster experiences,
because your users
are just going away
when this doesn't happen.
And sometimes you
don't even notice.
So a lot of our effort
recently has been
about targeting this problem.
This is kind of the
number one problem
that we have is to allow us to
have really fast experiences
on mobile itself.
When we do things across
Chrome, across APIs,
across the platform,
CDNs, you name it,
we need to come
together to really fix
this problem for users.
Now the good news
is, you can do it.
You can provably do it.
We're seeing a lot of
partners coming out
with these new progressive web
apps that are showing this off.
So the "Washington
Post," they're
a news outlet over in the US.
And they went off and built
a new progressive web app.
And they focused a lot on this
exact issue, on performance.
And so they focused
on initial page loads.
And that was really great.
And then they're really
proud to also focus on,
once you've got
things loaded, they
have a nice rich
experience, lots of imagery.
It's not like they're not doing
anything and kind of having
a bare bones experience.
It's a great experience that
when you type on that article,
something's going to
load in 80 milliseconds.
They do a lot with prefetching.
They do a lot with service
worker caches, things
that we're going to
talk about later.
They're able to deliver
this really, really
beautiful experience.
And all of this technology
is available for you
to do the same thing.
One of the cute little
things that they did
was if you go to their
articles now and check it out,
they actually put
right into the article
how long it took to
render that article.
They're really putting
it front and center,
because I think that team is
just so proud of what they're
doing for performance.
And users are noticing.
So we need reliably
fast experiences,
and we also need
them to be engaging.
We need them to be really
fun and useful for users.
And we need you, the developer,
to be able to reach that user
and for them to be
able to reach them.
So the areas that we
think are most important
there are threefold.
First up, we need to
give you the capability
to get your web experience
on the home screen.
Again, we talked
about how loyal users,
they're the ones that want to
be able to add you to the home
screen so they can
come back to you easily
from wherever they are.
So we had to give the
API, as a platform, to you
folks to be able to
get access to that.
And that's been done with this
add to home screen feature
that you'll see.
But then, in exchange
for that, you
need to deliver the
experiences that people
want to add to the home screen,
and that meet the expectations
they have when they
tap on something
that's on the home screen.
The second thing we
need to be able to do
is allow you to develop a
truly immersive experience.
So that means you
get the full screen.
There's no browser Chrome
that's getting in the way,
or anything that just
doesn't feel quite right.
You get full access
to everything.
You can customize theme
colors on the headers
and do whatever you want.
So to the user, it just
feels like a fully immersive
experience.
And then thirdly, we need
access to notifications.
Now notifications have been
probably the biggest deal--
the biggest effect that we've
had with the world of mobile.
You think about it, what's the
big difference between going
from my laptop at
home or at work,
compared to what
happens now with mobile?
I've got this thing that's
with me at all times, 24/7.
I sometimes have to remember
to charge it and get it out
of my sight at home
so it doesn't start
kind of running my life for me.
But there's full access
available to every user,
that you can then
choose to use to be
able to give them information
that makes sense for them.
Now that doesn't
mean abusing this.
But if you do it
right, it's going
to enable you to have a
really excellent up leveling
of your engagement.
So here with push
notifications, just like Ben
said before, you can go through,
set something up, get a push
notification.
Doesn't matter if the browser
is open or anything like that.
It's going to come through
and get to your code
so you can show
something to the user
and then entice them back
into your experience.
This is a huge deal.
If you look at all of
our case studies, anyone
who uses push notifications,
you see the massive bump
that they get when
they use them.
We've got a whole session
on push notifications.
We also want to make
sure that our users are
protected, as always.
And so with
everything on the web,
you'll see that there's a
permissions model behind it.
And so when you think it's time
and you think it make sense
for push notifications
for the user,
the user can then go in
and allow or disallow
what's going on.
We also highly recommend that
you add notification settings.
So it's not just a
blanket statement of,
do I want push or not?
You have the ability
as a user to fine tune
really what I want
to get out of you.
And when we see
people doing that,
people are more apt to stay
with push notifications
and not turn them off.
So I really recommend
that you do that work.
OK, let's take a look at what
an immersive experience actually
looks like and how it works.
This example is from CNET.
CNET is a technology site.
And they went off,
one of their teams,
and put this into production
recently, a separate PWA that
was just kind of exploring
what something on tech,
with a few articles, could
be like as an immersive PWA
experience.
And so let's say you went
to the URL at the top there,
cnet.com/techtoday.
Or maybe you did a
search for something,
or maybe it comes from an email.
Anyway, you get the
URL, you tap on that.
You're now into this experience.
Very rich, very immersive--
you see at the top
there's that zero, one.
You can just flip through
these really nice articles
and experiences and then scroll
up and down and explore them.
Now, when it's
appropriate, when you've
got a user that's been
to your site regularly
and the like, the browser will
say to you as a developer, hey,
this might be a good
time to ask that user
if they want you to add your
experience to the home screen.
What people are really doing
here is thinking about,
when is the right time
to say that to the user?
So that may not be as soon as
we say, hey, it's available.
It may be waiting for
a particular action,
like when they've bought
something, maybe then say, hey,
maybe now is a good time for
you to track what's going on.
Sign up for push notifications.
Add me to the home
screen or whatever.
But here I go through,
I've got the standard UI.
I tap on Add to Home Screen.
It's now going to add
it in the background
and tell me along the bottom
there that it's been done.
And now, the user can kind
of go along, still browsing,
do their own thing.
Or they can go into the
immersive experience.
So let's say it's a month later.
The user wants to go back
into that experience.
And they go to
their home screen,
and they see that
the icon's there,
looks exactly the same
as their native app,
because it is the same thing.
They type on the app.
It then launches up.
You have full access
to this experience,
have a splash screen.
So while you're quickly loading
and getting things ready,
you can theme things that
make sense for your brand.
And then you get right
into the experience.
And what's the difference here?
The difference is there's
no URL bar at the top.
There's no notion of the fact
that this is using a browser
or using web
technologies at all.
And that's by design.
The user may have forgot where
they did the Add to Home Screen
from.
They don't know.
They don't care.
They just want to get
in there and start
using your experience.
Now, maybe they're going to the
task switcher at the bottom.
And then, again, the
representation that they get
is one where it just feels
like any old application.
It's just like a
native app to them,
and that's the whole point.
So, reliable, fast, and engaging
applications, that's the key.
How do we actually do this?
What's the technology
that's behind all of this?
It's what we talked
about in the keynote.
It's that service
worker technology.
And this is the fix
that we had to put in.
Again, when you're
connected to that dial up
and you've connected
your home to the web,
the browser's talking
to this web server,
and it's reliant on that
web server to do anything.
That's where it
needs to go to get
any of its logic
or its information.
And as soon as somebody
goes offline, you're toast.
You can't do anything
for the user.
So we had to create a service
worker, this technology that
allows you to build a proxy,
that's just JavaScript, that's
just a small piece of code
that you can install down
for the user.
So user comes to your site.
You download this piece of code.
And now you have full
control, full access
to watch what's going on.
So requests start coming in
from Flipkart, this experience.
And you can go through
and proxy that,
and say you know what, I've
got all of this information.
I've got the Chrome for
the actual app itself.
I'm going to grab
it from the cache,
or I'm going to
go and run a race.
I'm going to go to the
cache and return some data.
And then I'm going to go
to the website at the end.
And when new data
comes back from that,
I'll then update my application.
You can do whatever you want.
You have full
access and control.
Now, this is the base for a
lot of the different technology
that we're adding to
the web these days,
including push notifications.
So now, your
website, example.com,
sends a push message out.
It's going to end up coming over
to your little piece of code.
That just says, OK, here's
the event that's coming in.
You then get to do whatever
you want with that event,
probably ending up with
showing an actual notification
for the user.
You don't have to worry
about the lifecycle.
You don't have to
worry about was there
a service worker in memory,
or any of that stuff.
Doesn't matter if the
browser was there or not.
The whole operating system
will make sure that this works
and send you the
correct message.
Now, we talked about
Alibaba in the keynote,
and the work that they've been
doing in the world of commerce,
the increase in conversions
that they were getting,
and the fact that, I
don't know if you noticed,
where he talked about
the usage increase
across iOS and Android.
And to me it's
really interesting
that they got this
bump on Android,
that has service workers, but
they also got a bump on iOS.
But iOS doesn't support
service workers.
So what happened?
Why did they get a
bump in their usage?
The reason is, the key part
of progressive web apps
is the progressive part.
They went in and took
care of their experience.
With Safari, it may not
have service workers today,
but it has a lot of support for
now the latest specs on the web
components side.
It's got a lot of support for
doing things performantly.
And so by taking the care
and just starting there,
starting with the web
standards and the fundamentals
and then progressively
adding in service worker
support and extra
features, enabled
them to make things better for
all of their users, not just
for users that happen to be
on the latest and greatest.
This is really important.
We really care about
this at Google.
We're not just focused
about building things
for Chrome users.
Another thing that
they have access
to in the world of
commerce is really
cleaning up transactions.
So a key issue on
the web is signing up
or signing into a website.
We've all seen those forms that
are really ugly to fill out
and the like.
And we have new standards
with Credential Manager APIs
and the like on sign
up and payments,
on the payment side, where now
Alibaba can take all of this
and just keep streamlining
all of the work to just really
enable users to get in and
out and make their purchases.
So how do you
actually get started?
The basis of everything is
to make sure that you've
secured your web experience.
So this is the
key to everything.
You need to make sure that
you're getting on HTTPS.
The green lock is there.
The user knows it's secure.
We're moving, as a web platform,
all of the key capabilities
to be within a secure origin.
As we entrust you,
the developers,
with more native
capabilities, we
need to make sure that it's
getting access to your code
and the user isn't getting
fished into some other area
and bad things are happening.
So step one, if you
haven't done it,
is you need to immediately
get onto HTTPS.
From there you've got
a few different parts.
We've now worked with
a bunch of partners,
and there are
different ways that you
can go about actually getting
your experience up and running.
And we understand that people
work in their companies, work
in their businesses.
They can't all just
stop what they're doing
and just go off and build
a brand-new experience.
We need to have
different tactics.
And we've seen three
patterns really show through.
We're going to talk about
going from the ground up,
just doing a full rewrite.
This is the dream.
This is the dream
for me as an engineer
to have full greenfield
to go build things.
So that's ideal.
You may not be able to do that.
And so another option is
to do a simple version
of what you're building.
And we'll talk
about that approach.
And then finally you
can just go and take
one API from the PWA landscape
and just go deep on that API
and start building from there.
Let's take a look at one of the
examples of going ground up.
This is a Nigerian e-commerce
company called Konga.
And a lot of their customers
are on 2G connections.
They really care about
connectivity and delivering
fast experiences.
And so they took
one of their teams
that had actually native
developers, as well as web
developers, and they
built from scratch
a new checkout flow using
all of the new capabilities.
And it's really cool
how even like right now
it's using this phone support.
They go through and make sure
that even when they're offline,
you can still check out, and
with the last option being,
we're really sorry we
can't do anything online.
But hey, just call us
and our customer support
will get this through.
So they've really
thought end to end
about the entire experience.
So they did this from scratch.
They pushed it out there.
And they were really
surprised to see
that the amount of data
that they were using
was dramatically less than
their pretty lightweight Android
application.
So they're able to get much
better performance out of this.
In areas where data costs a lot
of money, this was a big deal.
This was a big side
effect for them.
And then they also
measure something
that was really
interesting to me,
which was the amount
of time, amount of data
to get a transaction.
And they found that once
again, through that flow,
they could drop 82% of that
data out of that transaction.
This is a massive
deal for folks working
in these types of environments.
Another e-commerce
company, Flipkart,
they went through and did a PWA.
They were one of the earliest
groups that did this.
Another focus for them
was, in India, they
kept running into the issue of
having to get APK size really,
really small.
And so if you compare their
native application, which
is the Flipkart one there
to the Flipkart Lite
application, which is a
PWA, you see it's not just
like a little bit less.
It's over 300 times smaller.
So they're able to get
people into that application
in no time.
You're talking about
kilobytes, not megabytes.
This was a massive
deal for their users
and for their business.
So if you can, doing
a ground up approach
is going to get you a
fantastic experience.
Let's take a look
at a simple version.
Air Berlin, in the
travel industry,
they didn't have time to do the
full ground up rewrite first.
So they thought about the
different user journeys
that they have.
And one of them that's
really important
that they were failing was
not picking your flight
and purchasing your flight or
any of that side of things,
but actually after that.
And what's the
experience like where
you show up at the
airport and you just
want to get access to your
itinerary, your boarding pass,
all of your information?
And so they focused
on that piece.
They flushed out
that feature set.
And they built this
little PWA experience
that would guarantee
you, the customer,
to be able to get access
to all of that information
and make sure that it works
offline, because we've all been
to airports where the
Wi-Fi is a little bit shaky
and the cell networks
aren't working that great.
So they put through all of this
work, and they found at the end
that the load time was
less than a second.
So they're able to bring this
really niche use case that
was really vital for
their users and deliver
that outside of the bounds
of their main desktop web
application and the like.
They're able to
just kind of really
focus in and do a
great job with that.
OK, the final approach is
taking one part of the API,
or one API from
the myriad of APIs
that we have in the world
of progressive web apps.
So a great example of that
is weather.com, where again,
what was really important
to them was re-engagement.
If you think about a
site like weather.com,
it may not be the kind of site
that everyone is refreshing
every hour.
What's the weather now?
How's it changed?
It's not that kind
of experience.
So instead, they
wanted to think about,
how do I reach those users?
How do I reach them to tell
them it's going to rain
or there's a dramatic
difference in the weather?
Well the best way to do that
is through push notifications.
They were used to that
in the native world,
but a lot of users don't need
to have something on the home
screen or fully native
just to know a little bit
about what's going
on with that weather.
So what they did was they went
big on push, and push only,
and they launched it to over
60-plus languages globally.
And when they did that, they
were able in just a few months,
just three months, get over a
million people using those push
notifications.
So you think about their
business and the amount
of re-engagement
you get when you
have a million people in there
being notified when something's
changing.
That's a massive
leap in the curve
of user engagement for them.
So, you've got a
menu of choices.
You need to really think about
what makes for you, depending
on the company that
you're at, the legacy code
base that you may have.
Are you ready and
primed for a rewrite
to do something different?
There's a lot of different
things that are out there.
And we'd love to hear from
you, over in the web booth,
and after talks and the like,
to have us help in any way
on what the right choice is
and what makes sense for you.
We also want to guide
you in other ways.
Ben talked about how
we've got a new developer
side out there that's targeted
towards this region, which
is really exciting.
We've got a lot
of our web content
up there available to you.
But we also want to
do more than that.
We want to have tools that kind
of walk you through the path.
The web is a really
big platform.
You can do so much
with it, and it
can be a little bit daunting
to think about, well
what do I do next?
How do I take on this
big, big challenge?
And so we started
to think about,
what can we do to
help web developers?
And we came up with this tool
that we called Lighthouse
because it's trying to kind
of light the way for you.
And so the vision for this is
that you're running this all
the time on your application.
And it's giving you a score
and giving you information
on what's working and
what isn't working.
So it's going to hold you
accountable to your performance
to make sure that
you're doing a great job
with that performance, and it's
going to give you hints on what
to do to make things faster.
This started off with
a lot of information
on the performant side.
But, this is an
open source project,
and we've been building more and
more new rules into the system.
And so there's this whole notion
that we call "do better web"
that's in there that's just
watching your application
and it's telling you things.
In the world of AI
and machine learning,
we should be able to go
in, look at our code bases,
start to see patterns,
and start telling you
as developers what are things
that you should notice.
And so I really recommend that
you take a look at Lighthouse.
And we have a whole
talk today that's
all about tools,
including Lighthouse.
This is going to be able to
walk you through the process
and kind of, hopefully, hold
your hand a little bit as we
go along with that,
and then linking
into all of the
rich documentation
that we have available.
So it's been kind of a wild
ride for us over the last year.
I'd say we've got the technology
out there at the bleeding
edge a couple of years ago.
But then over the last year,
the whole browser community
has really come
together and started
getting the capabilities across
lots of different browsers.
The web frameworks communities
have really come together.
It's a big effort for us to
be able to build for mobile.
There's totally
different constraints
that we have to be aware of.
And so that's why you see that
Angular is creating an Angular
2, because you need
to think differently
when you build for mobile.
And we see similar
things happening
in the world of React.
We have a framework
called Polymer
that sits within the
Chrome team that's really
trying to push the boundaries
and be kind of like the Tesla
for what it means to
take web standards
and build something
really quickly on mobile.
So the framework communities
are coming together.
And now it's up to us as
just general web developers
to come together to deliver this
functionality for our users.
So if there's one thing I ask
and that you take away from
is, really appreciate you
coming here to listen,
to hear what we have to say.
This is a big revolution
for us on the web,
and there's a lot of work for us
to make this just really killer
on mobile.
And we think that we've
got the capabilities that
allow you to help us
cause an extinction
to the whole dinosaur race,
so to speak, and get rid
of those offline dinosaurs.
With that, [CHINESE], thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thanks, Steven,
for the great keynote.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
SPEAKER 3: OK, let me
translate the questions.
So the audience is asking,
she saw all these examples
about e-commerce.
She was wondering
whether there are
more examples around
small games and et cetera.
SPEAKER 1: Right, got it.
OK great, thank
you, good question.
So games is an
interesting venue for us.
We're seeing that there's a
lot of new web games being
created and being
put into other areas
where things work on the web.
So recently, for
example, Facebook just
announced gaming
on their platform,
and it uses web as
its core technology.
And so if you think
back to the old days
of Flash games and
the like, there
was a real community of
doing games on the web.
And we're starting to
see that more and more.
And with a lot of
the key capabilities
that we're talking
about here, you
need your game to work offline.
You know, all of these
things can very much
be used in the world of games.
And so we're seeing
a large push.
The initial push was
kind of publishing,
and then e-commerce.
And then the newest
thing, these days,
is around the kind
of gaming vertical.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I saw the cute
dinosaur on your mic.
So a lot of your technology you
talk about, and in this country
we have some network
issues such as GFW.
And if I want to
use my next service
to use that push service, then
there will be a problem here.
If there is some
network issue, what
will we do about a web
push, especially in China?
Yes, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Got it.
Great, great question.
So the question is,
different regions have
very different constraints.
They have users using
different browsers.
They have the constraints that
you mentioned with networking
issues and the like.
And so what we're trying
to do as a web community
there is to work
really closely with all
of the different browser vendors
and CDN providers and everyone
we can to be able to
deliver these capabilities.
So the whole reason that Web
Push exists the way it does
is that it's an open standard
that anyone can implement.
So it's not a Google push
or anything like that.
It's fully open.
And so what we're finding,
especially as of late,
a lot of the browser
vendors are really
coming together to tackle
these kind of problems.
But one of the reasons
that we're here
is to learn from
you folks on what
are the things that
aren't working here
and what you need from us.
That's a great point.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm an Android
application developer.
If I want to replace some
of my function with web,
can I benefit from a PWA?
If I can, how?
SPEAKER 1: Got it.
So Android developer thinking
about how does the PWA fit in.
So I think there's always a
role for native development.
That's not going away anywhere.
What PWA really is about
is up leveling the web
to take on the most
important capabilities.
And so what we're
finding more and more
is that to reach these users,
instead of just trying to block
and force them to
install your application,
depending on what
you're building,
it actually seems
to make more sense
to have something for them that
they can actually start using.
So depending on what you're
building, you can think about,
how much could you do
on the web there now
that we've kind of up
leveled, and what makes sense?
And then if there
are some capabilities
that the web doesn't have yet,
you've got a path onto native.
And we're working on
getting more and more
of these paths set up for you.
But we think time
and time again,
across a lot of the
verticals, we actually
can give you what you need
for a lot of use cases
just using the web.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I want to know, as a user, how
can I get into the PW web set,
and send them, such as
throughout the search all
the web set, and so on?
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Got it.
So I think the question is, as a
user, how do I find these PWAs?
How do I actually use
them and the like?
One of the really nice
things about PWAs,
for a long time we
kept hearing about,
you've got these app stores.
Where's the web app store?
And Chrome came out with the
Chrome Web Store and the like.
And we have some of
these sites, like there's
a site called pwa.rocks.
That's a catalog,
more for developers,
for us to get inspiration
on different PWAs.
But the real beauty
about PWAs is
you don't need to go to
a store to download them.
And you can go ahead and
use search or get access
through WeChat and the
like through a link,
and you get access to
this rich application.
And so once you have this,
all through the power of URLs,
you can use anything that you
want to get your message out
to users to get
them to then start
getting real benefit and value
from using your application.
And then at the very
end, the loyal users
will want to do
Add to Home Screen.
But you don't have to ask all
of your user base to think, OK,
do you want the app on day one?
You can get, again,
progressively
allow that to unfold for them.
AUDIENCE: I know that Chrome
has much APIs to support PWA.
But I want to know if
users use either browsers
or other operating systems,
my PWA apps can work perfectly
on these other platforms.
SPEAKER 1: Great,
great question.
So once again, users use
lots of different browsers,
lots of different platforms.
Chrome has a lot of
these great PWA APIs,
but not every browser does.
So the good news there
is that Firefox, Opera,
a lot of these folks are
implementing, and have
implemented--
Microsoft Edge and the like--
a lot of these APIs.
So the APIs are coming quickly.
But again, the
whole point of PWA
is that progressive
where, as the user gets
more capabilities,
you can then do
something new with that user.
And if you think about a world
where you have chat interfaces
and Google Home Voice
interfaces, and you separate
all of the different pieces
of what it takes to actually
interact with something,
it's a really nice way
to develop services
and applications,
because now with
that Voice UI, you
may want to show something
that you can actually
pick in a UI that's visual, and
the web is perfect for that.
And so it's a different
way of thinking.
You can go responsive.
You can go across
desktop, mobile.
As a capability is available,
you just then get to use it.
And again, you don't have to
make this binary choice of yes
or no.
And the good news
from our side is just,
we've been really excited
with how quickly the browser
community is working
on these features.
The other side of it is,
you still have access
through other means, like
Cordova and the like,
to be able to bridge into native
from your web technology too.
So if there's that one API
that you really need to use
and you want to get it in the
store, you can take your app,
you can use Cordova
and get access to that
and put it in a store.
So you have lots of
different escape hatches.
SPEAKER 3: I think this will be
the last question, because we
need to leave like--
or it's already.
SPEAKER 2: I think we can
actually have two more.
SPEAKER 3: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, I'll start from--
[CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have question about,
is there some possibility
in the future that the PWA
special feature like pushing
future can run in iOS device?
And is there Google can
talk about this with Apple
in future?
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Yes, thank you.
So I obviously can't
speak for Apple.
We would love to have PWAs
running in Safari and iOS.
The good news again
recently is, if you
look at what Apple
is coming out with,
the recent support for
different specs and web
components and the like, we
feel really good at the progress
that they're making towards
all of the key things that
go into progressive web app.
And so we're really hopeful.
We've got actually
really good relationships
with the Safari team itself.
They tend to be fairly
secretive and the like,
and we respect that.
But we're seeing things
going in the right direction.
So we think that's
going to come on iOS.
But once again, we want to
build other tools that allow
you to still get on to iOS.
So one being the
progressive nature--
you can build a great experience
and you see big uptake.
And the other being
PhoneGappy type
solutions to enable yourself
to take that technology
and get it into a native app.
SPEAKER 2: OK, so this
will be the last question.
And before that, I
would ask [INAUDIBLE]
to remind lunch is served
on the fourth floor.
And the afternoon sessions
is going to start at 12:30.
So we're going to have a
whole lot more excellent talks
and deep dive into afternoon.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I've
got one question.
For native apps,
we know native apps
can interact with other native
apps we intend or deep link.
So does PWA support the
interact with other native apps
or PWA apps?
SPEAKER 1: Great, that's
a fantastic question.
So the question was, on
Android, for example,
you have intents and
a way for native apps
to talk to each other.
How does that work
in the world of PWAs?
So when you install
a PWA in Android,
you actually are
installing an APK itself.
And so you are able to interact.
And we're doing a lot of work
right now on setting things
up so you can interact really
nicely between the two.
If you take a look,
we just talked
about a new API
called the Web Share
API that allows you to
do sharing, rich sharing,
from within the worlds of PWAs.
And so as you imagine this world
with these PWAs as just APKs,
and that you could set
up intents and the like,
the whole power of
the web is the fact
that you can compose
things with mashups
and tie things
together with URLs.
And so we're going to be
putting a lot of effort
in to make that
really work well,
both between PWAs and also PWAs
connected with native apps.
And we're really
excited about that.
Thank you.
So again, we've run out
of time now, but thanks
so much for spending
time with us.
And I can't wait to see
what you guys develop.
[CHINESE]